Hello everyone, I'm VOA's Rebecca Ward.
And we're going green whenever and wherever we can.
We go to Kenya for this first story...
...and speak with the coauthor of a study about the danger facing some native species.
Wild grazing animals are disappearing from Kenya's cherished Masai Mara National Reserve.
That's according to a new study by the Nairobi-based International Livestock Research Institute.
The reason, says in the report,...
...is human encroachment on the borders of the reserve.
Joseph Ogutu co-authored the study.
He spoke to us by phone from Nairobi.
One of the significant causes of the decline is just the loss of the habitat...
...and then the deduction in the quality of the habitat or...
...the degradation of the habitat if you like.
Another thing is the increase in the number of settlements...
...and these are on ranch lands which are bordering the south.
What you're seeing in the Mara is just one example...
...of a general pattern that is actually happening all over Kenya.
Researchers say more permanent human settlements have led to dramatic drops in populations of six hoofed species...
...including giraffes, impala, and warthogs.
The study appears in next month's British Journal of Zoology.